jay and michael were a pair of urban
exploration youtubers looking for their
big break
you might remember their video exploring
the dead mall on the outskirts of your
town
or the supposedly haunted 1950s insane
asylum
out in sticks but you certainly won't
find these videos anywhere
online after the incident at scp-823
all of their content was scrubbed away
from even the most comprehensive
internet archives why you ask because
these unfortunate urban explorers
decided that their big break
would be exploring a certain abandoned
theme park
and it would be one of the last
decisions they ever made
michael and jay had heard rumors about
the theme park its name was lost to time
as was the date of its opening and
closing and the reason it was even
abandoned
in the first place even some of the most
hardcore urban explorers didn't dare to
tread there
something about it a good friend had
once told jay just didn't feel
right sometimes if you dare to venture
into the forest near the theme park at
night
you can still hear music the jolly
piping tunes of rides and carnival
stands still beckoning
as if to say we're still here come and
play
of course none of this frightened jay
and michael they could already smell the
sponsorships from headlamp and compact
camera companies
no amount of anxiety would stop them
from making their doomed trip to the
so-called
carnival of horrors it's a terrible
shame
if they'd listen to the stories of this
place about how unnatural
and evil it could be they might still be
alive today
like all the best urban explorers they
arrived at the woods near the abandoned
theme park in the dead of night
they ignored the signs warning them
about everything from structural
instability
to dangerous wild animals to asbestos
nothing would keep them out nothing
they reached the abandoned theme park
not long after though was a mere shell
of its former self
during the several decades of
abandonment nature had reclaimed it
the ferris wheel was covered in
overgrown ivy and the carnival stands
were blanketed with mold
as the duo swept through the grounds
with their flashlights and cameras
they saw a faded sign that bore the
words thriller chiller
the park's most popular roller coaster
they also took their time to marvel
at the exceptionally creepy looking
tunnel of love the broken down house of
mirrors
and a huge grinning statue of the park's
former mascot
happy hippo this theme park was
something out of a nightmare
which naturally made it potential video
gold but as the excited duo wandered
further into the park
they couldn't help but notice the quiet
tinny carnival music
music that seemed to be drawing them
closer michael asked jay
if he could hear the strange impossible
music and felt a chill creep in when he
answered that he did
could all the stories be true they were
lost in thought
but their legs kept moving they were
getting closer to something now
they could feel a presence and was that
music getting louder
an instant later though another sound
cut through the silence
bang bang it echoed out through the
still night air
birds flew from their perches in the
trees jay and michael both fell to the
ground
dead their heads taken off by the 50
caliber rounds of a highly trained
mobile task force sniper on the payroll
of the scp
foundation their recording equipment
along with their bodies were taken and
destroyed
any trace of them were scrubbed from the
internet it may seem a little harsh
but a bullet to the head is much kinder
faith than what would have awaited these
two
if they'd kept walking that's because
the carnival of horrors is no
dark fairy tale the rumors are all true
and something really is
waiting in the dark that's why this
abandoned theme park is known to the scp
foundation as
scp-823 a euclid-class anomaly with a
violent history
what's even more unnerving is that the
researchers studying 823 have repeatedly
implored the o5 council to
increase the park's classification to
ketir and allocate more resources for
containment
only to be denied but after you've heard
about the horrors that unfolded there
and the danger it poses you'll probably
take the researcher's side
the park is divided into two zones the
yellow zone
and the red zone there are to be at
least six members of foundation
personnel present in the yellow zone at
all times to ensure that no civilians
wander in
our two urban explorers earn themselves
a death sentence not just by wandering
into the yellow zone
but passing dangerously close to the red
zone
this is the true epicenter of the park's
dangerous anomalous activity it's a
place so hazardous that anyone entering
whether they're a civilian or a member
of foundation staff
is to be executed at a distance by
sniper fire without hesitation
once upon a time though nobody knows
exactly when
there was a theme park that seemed no
different to any other
eager children and thrill-seeking teens
arrived by the bustler
ready to stuff their faces with cotton
candy and corndogs
and then reverse the process on a vast
array of roller coasters
but even then during these good times
there was something dark lurking behind
the cheerful facade
little by little everyone visitors and
employees alike
started falling victim to strange and
horrific accidents around the park
of course when it comes to theme parks
accidents come with a territory
but none like this here are just a
handful of the horrific
and mysterious deaths that occurred
while the park was open
so strap in because just like a roller
coaster
this isn't for the faint of heart a pair
of young lovebirds decided they wanted
to enjoy the romance of the tunnel of
love
the two sat in a swan-shaped boat as
they were ferried through darkened
passageways
anyone would assume that they were
having a great time but at some point
terrible shrieks of pain and fear began
to echo through the ride
attendants confused and terrified
stopped the ride and found that the
screaming persisted
just some stupid teens playing a prank
they figured and
started the ride again but when the
swan-shaped boat finally exited the
tunnel of love
the park employees were greeted to a
horrifying sight
the two teens dead their bodies somehow
fused together at multiple points
another unlucky customer met a gruesome
fate inside the house of mirrors
they entered but while inside they were
stalked by a mysterious
carnivorous humanoid entity known as
subject 79
the customer was pursued and eventually
caught by subject 79
and brutally dismembered some parts of
the body were fused to the house of
mirror's interior
while others like the right arm were
never found
the customer actually survived their
ordeal and whether that's a happy ending
is up to you but it wasn't just the
customers at the park who were in danger
a 23 year old park employee working a
summer job
collapsed while entertaining children
dressed as the park's cheerful mascot
happy hippo it wasn't uncommon for
people to get overheated and collapse in
the heavy suits on hot days
but one thing was different here he was
screaming
crying and trying desperately to remove
his mask
people rushed to help but nobody could
get the suit off
and he was declared dead soon after when
he was eventually cut out of the suit
coroners found that the employee had
choked to death his mouth
trachea and lungs were filled with a
fibrous substance later determined to be
identical to the stuffing of his costume
an intense roller coaster known as the
thriller chiller was a magnet for
horrific accidents
which became more violent and intense
over time
the first accident seemed like a typical
theme park tragedy
a safety harness failed dropping a rider
15 feet
during an inverted loop they landed on
the track below
breaking their neck and skull causing
instant death
while this was a tragedy it wasn't
exactly anomalous
but the next major accident on the ride
was an entirely different story
this time 15 people met with disaster
while riding the thriller chiller roller
coaster
starting from the front and moving back
one car at a time
each group of riders was decapitated by
blunt force trauma
a new pair of decapitations appeared to
happen at every turn and loop on the
ride
forensic scientists still have no idea
how this could have possibly occurred
despite all of these disasters the park
was only finally abandoned
after a day known as bloody sunday when
the anomalous powers of the location
reached a 20-year peak it's believed
that 231 people were killed during the
carnage of that day
and another seven were horribly maimed
the scp foundation contained the
carnival of horrors not long after
but the mysterious deaths didn't even
end there foundation mobile task force
row 71
also known as the origami toads were
sent in to assess containment procedures
and discover the source of all the
anomalous deaths
they were unsuccessful though and
instead they merely added to the list
in exceptionally horrifying ways one
agent was found dead
surrounded by empty grenades and bullet
casings it appeared he'd removed the
explosive propellant from all of his
ballistics and consumed it
dying in the process another was found
with his jaw
broken having apparently pulled out and
inhaled his own teeth
and dying of the resulting internal
damage the commander got the worst fate
of all
so horrifying in fact that we can't tell
you the full details
all you need to know is that something
was shoved into his brain that
really didn't belong there the
foundation considered having the entire
park destroyed with a massive air strike
courtesy of the mobile task force news 7
aka
hammer down however the o5 council
denied this request
on the basis that the park was too close
to populated land
they'd have no plausible cover story for
the bombing and they don't even really
know if blowing up the park would
prevent anomalous activity from
occurring
the carnival of horrors is here to stay
folks the foundation
just hopes to keep it from getting new
visitors
so then back to why the researchers want
this place upgraded to ketir
after all these classifications aren't
about how dangerous an anomaly is
they're about how difficult and
complicated they are to contain
but here's the problem according to the
researchers the red zone
where the dangerous anomalous activity
is at its peak
isn't bound to one fixed position it's
changed position at least three times
already and even worse
it appears to be growing not seemingly
so euclid class now
is it after all you might not even need
to visit the carnival of horrors to be
in grave danger
if it keeps growing then someday soon
the carnival of horrors
may be visiting you now go check out
scp-2000
deus ex machina and scp-4205
in the eyes of the beholder for more
existentially terrifying
scps